taken from someone who's run a virtual
company for over a decade
um trying to build trust without any
kind of uh
human contact is way more difficult and
i think one of the big mistakes that a
lot of organizations have made
is because we've adapted reasonably well
to teleworking
we're missing the fact that many of the
relationships pre-existed
you know we're we know these people good
luck building trust with somebody who's
entirely new to the team and has never
met anyone
uh that's very different because
remember you know
we build trust between the meetings
isaac stern said
music uh happens between the notes well
trust happens between the meetings
you build trust when you're walking in
and you're a little early and you're
making small talk
you build trust as you're walking out
and you're still talking about the
meeting as you're walking out
you build trust when you bump into
somebody in a hallway and you go oh i've
been meaning to talk to you
you build trust when you knock on
someone's door and you say you got a
minute
you build trust when you say you want to
meet you want to have lunch and it's
these social interactions over and over
and over again no one of them does it
but but like brushing your teeth you
know brushing your teeth for two minutes
there's nothing
do it twice a day every day it keeps
your teeth clean right
one of those things does nothing but the
consistency in the of the that human
interaction over time
builds this thing called trust and it's
way more difficult to do not impossible
to do but way more difficult to do
virtually because now you actually have
to schedule that time
because there is no such thing as
between the meeting you show up for the
call and that's it
you have the call and when the call is
done you all get enough there's no human
interaction
um and so the way you do it is is you
have to schedule times for
for personal stuff like you actually
have team huddles
where you get on a monday and you say
what's on your heart and mind and here's
a fun
or poignant question to answer let's go
around the room and you do not talk shop
at all
you don't talk about what the schedule
is you don't talk about results you
don't talk about the work
you give people an opportunity to share
what's on their heart and mind
you you know you have virtual lunches
with people
where you log on and just have a lunch
and even then even on virtual teams you
still want to meet at least once a year
as a group uh to solidify those bonds
and by the way
brainstorming sessions anything to do
with ideas oh my god they're impossible
to do virtually
you just don't have the same flow of
ideas you can't interrupt each other
easily
you know interrupting each other
virtually is rude and disruptive
interrupting each other you know in a
meeting where there's 10 of us is easy
it's no big deal you can have four
people talking at the same time
and it's fun um because we're all in the
same flow and
in the idea generation so i think we
have to accept
that yes the ability to tell a work
means that we can keep these
organizations functional and moving
during these pandemic times
and for companies that think they never
need to go back to the office they're in
for a shock
i think what will happen and i think if
you asked me to envision the future of
work
is especially in the military you didn't
realize you had this component until you
were forced to
um uh and i think what will happen both
in
in in military and in private sector is
things will become a little more fluid
where people actually have the option to
telework when they can and when they
need to
so it's not like hey you know next
thursday do you mind if
it'll happen where somebody just emails
in the morning saying i'm working from
home today
and it's fine it just becomes a fluid
part of our work day
and way more socially acceptable um
people working a half day in the office
people working a half day from home
because they got to deal with something
they don't need to take a day off
you know it just becomes a lot more uh
more flexible i think that's
more likely some sort of balanced
[Music]
equation